foreign
I went to bed early
sometimes my candle scarcely out my eyes
would close so quickly that I didn't
have time to say to myself I'm falling
asleep
and half an hour later the thought that
it was time to try to sleep would wake
me I wanted to put down the book I
thought I still had in my hands and blow
out my light
I hadn't ceased while sleeping to form
Reflections on what I just read
but these Reflections are taken a rather
peculiar turn it seemed to me that I
myself was what the book was talking
about and Church quartet the Rivalry
between frostwa the first and Charles V
this belief lived on for a few seconds
after my waking
shock my reason but lay heavy like
scales on my eyes and kept them from
realizing that the Candlestick was no
longer lit
then it began to grow unintelligible to
me as after metam psychosis do the
thoughts of an earlier existence
the subject of the book detached itself
from me
I was free to apply myself to it or not
immediately I recovered my sight and I
was amazed to find a Darkness all around
me soft and restful for my eyes
perhaps even more so for my mind to
which it appeared a thing without cause
incomprehensible a thing truly dark
I would ask myself what time it might be
I could hear the whistling of the trains
which remote or nearby like the singing
of a bird in a forest plotting the
distances described to me the extent of
the deserted Countryside where the
traveler hastens towards the nearest
station
and the Little Road he is following will
be engraved on his memory by the
excitement he owes to new places to
unaccustomed activities to the recent
conversation and the farewells under the
unfamiliar lamp that follow him still
through the Silence of the night
the imminent sweetness of his return
I would rest my cheeks tenderly against
the lovely cheeks of the pillow which
Full and fresh are like the cheeks of
our childhood
I would strike a match to look at my
watch
nearly midnight
this is the hour when the sick man who's
been obliged to go off on a journey and
has had to sleep in an unfamiliar Hotel
awakened by an attack is cheered to see
a ray of light under the door
how fortunate it's already morning
in a moment the servants will be up he
will be able to ring someone will come
to help him
the hope of being relieved gives him the
courage to suffer
in fact he thought he heard footsteps
the steps approach
then recede and the ray of light that
was under his door
has disappeared
it's midnight they've just turned off
the gas the last servant has gone and he
will have to suffer the whole night
through without remedy
I would go back to sleep and sometimes
afterwards woke only briefly for a
moment long enough to hear the organic
Creek of the woodwork opened my eyes and
stare at the Kaleidoscope of the
darkness
Savor in a momentary glimmer of
Consciousness the Sleep into which were
plunged the furniture the room that
whole of which I was only a small part
and whose insensibility I would soon
return to share
or else while sleeping I had
effortlessly returned to a forever
vanished period of my early life
rediscovered one of my childish Terrors
such as that my great uncle would pull
me by my curls
a terror dispelled on the day the dawn
for me of a new era when they were cut
off
I'd forgotten that event during my sleep
I recovered its memory as soon as I
managed to wake myself up to escape the
hands of my great uncle
but as a precautionary measure I would
completely surround my head with my
pillow for returning to the world of
Dreams
sometimes as Eve was born from one of
Adam's Ribs a woman was born during my
sleep from a cramped position of my
thigh
formed of the pleasure I was on the
point of enjoying she I imagined was the
one offering it to me
my body which felt in hers my own warmth
tried to return to itself inside her
I woke up
the rest of humanity seemed very remote
compared with this woman I'd left
scarcely a few moments before
my cheek was still warm from her kiss my
body aching from the weight of hers
if sometimes happened she had the
features of a woman I had known in life
I would devote myself entirely to this
end to finding her again like those who
go off on a journey to see a longed full
City with their own eyes and imagine
that one can enjoy in reality the charm
of a dream
little by little the memory of her would
fade I'd forgotten the girl of my dream
a sleeping man holds in a circle around
him the sequence of the hours the order
of the years and worlds
he consults them instinctively as he
wakes and reads in them in a second the
point on the earth he occupies the time
that has elapsed up to his waking
but their ranks can be mixed up broken
if towards morning after a bout of
insomnia sleep overcomes him as he is
Reading in a position too different from
the one in which he usually sleeps his
raised arm alone is enough to stop the
Sun and make it Retreat and in the first
minute of his waking he will no longer
know what time it is he will think he is
only just gone to bed if he dozes off in
a position still more displaced and
Divergent for instance after dinner
sitting in an armchair then the
confusion among the disordered worlds
will be complete the magic armchair will
send him traveling at top speed through
time and space
and at the moment of opening his eyelids
he will believe he went to bed several
months earlier in another country but it
was enough if in my own bed my sleep was
deep and allowed my mind to relax
entirely
then it would let go of the map of the
place where I had fallen asleep and when
I woke in the middle of the night since
I didn't know where I was I didn't even
understand in the first moment who I was
all I had in its original Simplicity was
the sense of existence as it may quiver
in the depths of an animal
I was more bereft than a caveman
but then the memory not yet of the place
where I was but of several of those
where I had lived and where I might have
been would come to me like help from on
high to pull me out of the Void from
which I couldn't have got out on my own
I passed over centuries of civilization
in one second
the image confusedly glimpsed of oil
lamps then of wing collar shirts
gradually recomposed myself's original
features
perhaps the immobility of the things
around us is imposed on them by our
certainty that they are themselves and
not others by the immobility of our
minds confronting them
however that may be when I woke thus my
mind restlessly attempting without
success to discover where I was
everything revolved around me in the
darkness things countries years my body
too but numbed to move would try to
locate according to the form of its
fatigue the position of its limbs in
order to deduce from this the direction
of the wall the location of the
furniture in order to reconstruct and
name the dwelling in which it found
itself its memory the memory of Its Ribs
its knees its shoulders offered in
succession several of the rooms where it
had slept well around it the invisible
walls changing Place according to the
shape of the imagined room spun through
the shadows and even before my mind
which hesitated on the thresholds of
times and shapes had identified the
house by reassembling the circumstances
it my body would recall the kind of bed
in each one the location of the doors
the angle at which the light came in
through the windows the existence of a
hallway
along with a thought I had had as I fell
asleep and that I'd recovered upon
waking
my stiffened side trying to guess its
orientation would imagine for instance
that it lay facing the wall in a big
canopied bed and immediately I would say
to myself why I went to sleep in the end
even though Mama didn't come to say
goodnight to me
I was in the country at the house of my
grandfather dead for many years and my
body the side on which I was resting
faithful guardians of a past my mind
ought never to have forgotten recall to
me the flame of the NightLight of
Bohemian glass in the shape of an urn
hanging from the ceiling by little
chains the mantelpiece of Sienna marble
in my bedroom at compreh at my
grandparents house in remote days which
at this moment I imagined were present
without picturing them to myself exactly
and which I would see more clearly in a
little while
fully awake then the memory of a new
position would be reborn the wall would
slip away in another Direction I was in
my room at Madame de saldos in the
country
but lord it's 10 o'clock or even later
that I finished dinner I must have
overslept in the nap I take every
evening when I come back from my walk
with Madame de salou before putting on
my evening clothes
for many years have passed since compreh
where however late we returned it was
the sunset's red Reflections I saw in
the Pains of my window
it's another sort of Life One leads at
thomsonville at Madame de San Luis
another sort of pleasure I take in going
out only at night in following By
Moonlight those Lanes where I used to
play in the Sun
and the room where I will have fallen
asleep instead of dressing for dinner
from far off I can see it as we come
back pierced by the flares of the lamp
lone beacon in the night these revolving
confused evocations never lasted for
more than a few seconds
in my brief uncertainty about where I
was I didn't distinguish the various
suppositions of which it was composed
any better than we isolate when we see a
horse run the successive positions shown
To Us by kinetoscope
but I'd seen sometimes one sometimes
another of the bedrooms I'd inhabited in
my life
and in the end I would recall them all
in the long reveries that followed my
waking
winter bedrooms in which soon as you're
in bed you bury your head in a nest that
you weave the most disparate things a
corner of the pillow the top of the
covers a bit of shawl the side of the
bed and an issue of the dubajors that
you end up by cementing together using
the birds technique of pressing down on
it indefinitely
where in icy weather the pleasure you
enjoy is the feeling that you're
separated from the outdoors like the sea
swallow which makes its nest deep in an
underground passage in the warmth of the
Earth
and where since the fire is kept burning
all night in the fireplace you sleep in
a great cloak of warm Smoky air pierced
by the glimmers from the logs breaking
into flame again a sort of immaterial
Alcove a warm cave hollowed in the heart
of the room itself a zone of heat with
moving thermal Contours aerated by
drafts that cool your face and come from
the corners from the parts close to the
window or far from The Hearth and that
have grown cold again summer bedrooms
where you love becoming one with a soft
Knight where the Moonlight leaning
against the half open shutters casts its
Enchanted ladder to the foot of the bed
where you sleep almost in the open air
like a tit Mouse rocked by the breeze on
the tip of a ray of light
sometimes the Louis XVI bedroom so gay
that even the first night I'd not been
too unhappy there and where the Slender
columns that lightly supported the
ceiling stood aside with such Grace to
show and reserve the place where the bed
was
sometimes on the other hand the small
bedroom with a very high ceiling
hollowed out in the form of a pyramid
two stories high and partly paneled in
Mahogany where from the first second I'd
been mentally poisoned by the unfamiliar
odor of the vetiver convinced of the
hostility of the Violet curtains and the
insolent indifference of the clock
chattering loudly as though I were not
there where strange and pitiless
quadrangular Cheval glass barring
obliquely one of the corners of the room
carved from deep inside the soft
fullness of my usual field of vision a
sight for itself which I'd not expected
where my mind struggling for hours to
dislodge itself to stretch upwards so as
to take the exact shape of the room and
succeed in filling its gigantic funnel
to the very top
had suffered many hard nights while I
lay at full length in my bed my eyes
lifted my ear anxious my nostril restive
my heart pounding until habit had
changed the color of the curtains
silenced the clock taught pity to the
cruel oblique mirror concealed if not
driven out completely the smell of the
vetiver and appreciably diminished the
apparent height of the ceiling
habit that's skillful but very slow
housekeeper who Begins by letting our
minds suffer for weeks in a temporary
Arrangement but whom we are nevertheless
very happy to find
for without habit and reduce to no more
than its own resources our mind would be
powerless to make a lodging habitable
certainly I was now Wide Awake My Body
had veered around one last time and the
good angel of certainty had brought
everything around me to a standstill had
laid me down under my covers in my
bedroom and had put approximately where
they belonged in the darkness my chest
of drawers my death
my fireplace the window on the street
and the two doors
even though I knew I was not in any of
the houses of which the ignorance of the
waking moment had instantly if not
presented me with a distinct picture at
least made me believe the presence
possible my memory had been stirred
generally I wouldn't try to go back to
sleep right away
I'd spent the greater part of the night
remembering our life in the old days in
compreh at my great aunt's house in
balbec in Paris in dossier in Venice
elsewhere still remembering the places
the people I'd known there what I'd seen
of them what I'd been told about them
every day beginning in the late
afternoon long before the moment when
I'd have to go to bed and stay there
without sleeping far away from my mother
and grandmother my bedroom again became
the fixed and painful locus of my
preoccupations they had indeed hit upon
the idea to distract me on the evenings
when they found me looking too unhappy
of giving me a magic lantern which while
awaiting the dinner hour they would set
on top of my lamp
after the fashion of the first
Architects and master glaciers of the
gothic age it replaced the opacity of
the walls with impalpable iridescences
Supernatural multi-colored apparitions
where Legends were depicted as in a
wavering momentary stained glass window
sadness was only increased by this
because the mere change in lighting
destroyed the familiarity my bedroom had
acquired for me which except for the
torment of going to bed had made it
tolerable for me
now I no longer recognized it and I was
uneasy there as in a room in some hostel
or Chalet to which I'd come for the
first time straight from the railway
train
moving at the jerky pace of his horse
gollo filled with a hideous design came
out of the small triangular Forest that
velveted the hillside with dark green an
advanced jolting towards the castle of
porge and viefta Bravo this Castle was
cut off along a curved line that was in
fact the edge of one of the glass ovals
arranged in the frame that you slipped
between the grooves of the lantern it
was only a section of Castle and it had
a moor in front of it where Jean viev
stood dreaming wearing a blue belt the
the castle and the Moor were yellow and
I hadn't had to wait to see them to find
out their color
since before the glasses of the frame
did so the bronze sonority of the name
Brabo had shown it to me clearly
gollo stopped for a moment to listen
sadly to the patter read out loud by my
great aunt which he seemed to understand
perfectly conforming his posture with a
meekness that didn't exclude a certain
Majesty that the directions of the text
then he moved off at the same jerky pace
and nothing could stop his Slow Ride
if the lantern was moved I couldn't make
out gollo's horse continuing to advance
over the window curtains swelling out
with their folds descending into their
fist shoots
the body of gollo himself in its Essence
is Supernatural as that of his mount
accommodated every material obstacle
every Henderson object that he
encountered by taking it as his skeleton
and absorbing it into himself even the
doorknob he immediately adapted to and
floated invincibly over with his red
robe or his pale face as Noble and as
Melancholy as ever but revealing no
disturbance at this transvertebration
certainly I found some charm in these
brilliant projections which seemed to
emanate from a Merovingian past and send
out around me such ancient reflections
of History
I cannot express the uneasiness caused
in Me by this intrusion of mystery and
Beauty into a room I had at last filled
with myself to the point of paying no
more attention to the room than to that
self
the anesthetizing influence of habit
having ceased I would begin to have
thoughts and feelings and they are such
sad things
that doorknob of my room which differed
for me from all the other doorknobs in
the world and that it seemed to open of
its own accord without my having to turn
it so unconscious had its handling
become for me was now serving as an
astral body for gollo
and as soon as they rang for dinner I
hastened to run to the dining room with
a big hanging lamp ignorant of gollo and
Bluebeard and well acquainted with my
family and beef
shed the same light as on every other
evening
and to fall into the arms of
Mama's misfortunes made all the dearer
to me while gollo's crimes drove me to
examine my own conscience more
scrupulously after dinner alas I soon
had to leave mama who stayed talking
with the others in the garden if the
weather was fine in the little drawing
room to which everyone withdrew if the
weather was bad
everyone except my grandmother who felt
that it's a Pity to shut oneself off
indoors in the country and who had
endless arguments with my father on days
when it rained too heavily because he
sent me to read in my room instead of
having me stay Outdoors
that's no way to make him strong and
active she would say sadly as especially
that boy who so needs to build up his
endurance and willpower my father would
shrug his shoulders and study the
barometer for he liked meteorology while
my mother making no noise so as not to
disturb him watched him with a tender
respect but not so intently as to try to
penetrate the mystery of his Superior
qualities
but as for my grandmother in all
weathers even in a downpour when
Francois had rushed the precious wicker
armchairs indoors for fear they would
get wet we would see her in The Empty
rain-lashed Garden pushing back had
disordered gray locks so that her
forehead could more freely drink in the
salubriousness of the wind and the rain
she would say at last one can breathe
and would roam the soaked paths to
symmetrically aligned for her liking by
the new Gardener who lacked all feeling
for nature and whom my father had been
asking since morning if the weather
would clear
with her jerky enthusiastic little step
regulated by the various emotions
excited in her soul by the intoxication
of the storm the power of good health
the stupidity of my upbringing and the
symmetry of the gardens
rather than by the desire quite unknown
to her to spare her plum colored skirt
the spots of mud under which it would
disappear up to a height that was for
her maid always a source of Despair and
a problem when these Garden walks of my
grandmothers took place after dinner
one thing had the power to make a
comeback in
this was at one of the times when her
circular itinerary brought her back
periodically like an insect in front of
the lights of the little drawing room
where the liqueurs were set out on the
card table if my great aunt called out
to her bet hild come and stop your
husband from drinking cognac to tease
her in fact she had brought into my
father's family so different a mentality
that everyone poked fun at her and
tormented her since liqueurs were
forbidden to my grandfather my great
aunt would make him drink a few drops
my poor grandmother would come in
ardently beg her husband not to taste
the cognac
he would become angry drink his mouth
full despite her and my grandmother
would go off again sad discouraged yet
smiling for she was so humble at heart
and so gentle that her tenderness for
others and the little fuss she made over
her own person and her sufferings came
together in her gaze in a smile in which
unlike what one sees in the faces of so
many people there was irony only for
herself and for all of us a sort of Kiss
From The Eyes which could not see those
she cherished without caressing them
passionately with her gaze this torture
my great aunt inflicted on her the
spectacle of my grandmother's vein and
treaties and of her weakness defeated in
advance trying uselessly to take the
liqueur glass away from my grandfather
were the kinds of things to the sight of
which you later became so accustomed
that you smile as you contemplate them
and take the part of the persecutor
resolutely and gaily enough to persuade
yourself privately that Lopez execution
is involved at that time they filled me
with such horror that I would have liked
to hit my great aunt but as soon as I
heard patil come and stop your husband
from drinking cognac already a man in my
cowardice I did what we all do once
we're grown up when confronted with
sufferings and injustices I didn't want
to see them
I went up to sob at the very top of the
house next to the school room under the
roofs in a little room that smelt of
Orris root and that was also perfumed by
a wild blackcurrant Bush which had
sprouted outside between the stones of
the wall and extended a branch of
flowers through the half open window
intended for a more specialized and more
vulgar use this room from which during
the day you could see all the way to the
keeper from which during the day you
could see all the way to the keep of
rosaville Lupa for a long time served me
as a refuge no doubt because it was the
only one I was permitted to lock for all
those occupations of mine that demanded
an inviolable solitude reading reverie
tears and sensual pleasure
alas I didn't know that much more than a
husband's little deviations from his
regimen it was my weak will my delicate
Health the uncertainty they cast and my
future that so sadly preoccupied my
grandmother in the course of those
incessant perambulations afternoon and
evening when we would see it as it
passed and then passed again lifted slot
wise Towards the Sky her beautiful face
with its Brown furrowed cheeks with
which age had become almost move like
the plowed fields in Autumn crossed if
she was going out by a veil half raised
while upon them brought there by the
cold or some sad thought an involuntary
tear was always trying